ah
never start with the head the victim
gets all fuzzy he can't feel the neck
see
you wanted me
here i am
i wanted to see what you do
and you didn't disappoint
you let five people die
then
you let den take your place
even to a guy like me that's cold
where's tent those mob fools want you
gone so they can get back to the way
things were
but i know the truth there's no going
back you've changed things
forever then why do you want to kill me
i don't want to kill you
what would i do without you go back to
ripping off mob dealers no no
no no you
you complete
me you're garbage you kills for money
don't talk like one of them you're not
even if you'd like to be
to them you're just a freak
like me
they need you right now
when they don't
they'll cast you out
like a leper
see they're morals they're code
it's a bad joke
i'm dropped at the first sign of trouble
they're only as good as the world allows
them to be
i'll show you when the chips are down
these uh these civilized people
they'll eat each other
see i'm not a monster
i'm just ahead of the curve
yes the only sensible way to live in
this world is without rules and tonight
you're gonna break your one rule i'm
considering it no there's only minutes
left so you're gonna have to play my
little game if you want to save one of
them
yeah
you know for a while there
i thought you really were down
the way you threw yourself after her
look at you go
does harvey know about you and his
little bunny
where are we
killing is making a choice
[Music]
you have
nothing
nothing to threaten me man
nothing to do with all your strength
don't worry i'm going to tell you where
they are
and that's the point
you'll have to choose
he's at 250 522nd street and she's uh on
avenue x that's just
which one you're going after